what the Democrats and the left made a
mistake about is that they didn't
realize that most Americans are not
voting for Trump because they're racist
misogynist and all that other stuff
they're voting for a guy because after
eight years with a Democratic president
Etc they had they still only had 500 in
the bank
and that's what matters to most
Americans I want to be able to send my
kid to baseball after school I want my
daughter to be able to take ballet
lessons I don't want to have to make a
decision between milk and ballet and if
you don't understand that that's the
case with most Americans then you aren't
around most Americans and for me you
know what I notice again is that and I'm
not saying the left doesn't have ideas
I'm not saying that it that a lot of
people on the left are people who tend
to be Democrats don't have aren't good
people don't have good ideas aren't part
of the mix aren't necessary for certain
things in society we need each other
I notice that the people that are that
are making a lot of the decisions the
people that come from a very expensive
unit fam a very privileged background a
family that's well connected with a lot
of money step into a very expensive
school with very expensive walls that
you can't get into and then they go
directly into a newsroom back into
Academia or right into politics or into
Hollywood what does that mean they
haven't come into contact with objective
reality enough they just haven't and I
promise you I promise you that most of
them have never had a plumber a
landscaper someone in the military or
anybody that works with their hands at
their dinner table
they are not it's not because they don't
want those people there they just don't
come into contact with them the people
of color they talk about the people that
actually need help I promise you they
don't know
and again I'm not saying it's their
fault I'm just saying it's what happens
we get very segregated and we are you
know you you fall into a class
substructure and you stay there man you
do and they have compassion they
probably have guilt they want to make a
difference in the world and they start
studying inequality and they start
seeing these things and you have an echo
chamber in these academic institutions
and nobody is pushing back there are no
conservative thinkers there just aren't
there are no uh there are no real
capitalists because that's not who gets
into Academia but look at look at the
difference between what happened with
Jon Stewart and Bill Maher you go back
five years ago who's who's God between
the two that's a great Jon Stewart
that's a great look what John so John
still wants to be invited to the same
parties with Obama still wants to be
invited to the same parties with you
know Hollywood whatever it is and Bill
Maher's like no no this is who I am and
listen if you're like me because as I
talked to every body on both sides and
this is what my comedy is and look how
much Bill Maher has changed
science we all agree it's true but but
what you're talking about is very hard
to do for a lot of people you know it's
very hard to do because he's like oh my
gosh but what what if this happens and
what if that happens no sometimes you
got to sit there and say you know I
don't know if I agree like okay so
kellyanne Conway is on The View I don't
know if you saw that or not she's on The
View and they started booing her and
then Whoopi's trying to play the role of
hey you know we're equal all this stuff
hey I don't care if you agree let her
finish her thought and then she says you
know uh uh uh something about Trump is
as I told Trump and Trump responds to
this it's hilarious he says while the
first uh Team Trump debunk okay former
president Donald Trump on Thursday
morning personally lashed out at
kellyanne Conway over her new Memoir
here's a deal in which she recalled
telling the ex-president that he
definitely lost the 2020 election while
the first term uh president Trump
rebuked in on Conway in her book this
week via spokesperson the latest lashing
was posted on Trump himself in the truth
social platform he says kellyanne Conway
never told me that she thought we lost
the election if she had I wouldn't have
dealt with her any longer she would have
been wrong could go back to her crazy
husband okay like yeah the problem with
Trump is a minute you were the minute
Hood pushed back the minute you push
back he said I don't like you yeah yeah
his loyalty lasts as long as you you
consider him God she is so listen so so
this was his most let me tell you his
advisor even she will go under that let
me put it to you this way let me put it
to you this way to me Kelly and Conway
is Tucker from Milwaukee Bucks when they
traded him to Miami okay you know what
I'm saying you need certain things
was Fearless yeah she was if by the way
if if he loses her if he loses her I'm
telling you right now it's gonna hurt
his chances if he loses Kelly on Conway
you can't lose Kelly that's a good point
you cannot lose Kelly uncommon it's like
it's got guts yeah you there's you you
cannot lose kellyanne Conway but at the
same time man you look at Trump to
respond away do you like Trump are you
worried that he's going to split the
ticket if I have to choose between
Santa's and Trump oh no the santis is
not running against Trump I know that
because I know that okay the sentence is
not around the center this was in our
community last Tuesday they did a
fundraiser last Tuesday in Bay Colony
the Santos is not running against Trump
now okay I could be wrong last minute
things can change because a part of me
we talk about it where we say you know
uh I think sometimes you think momentum
is going to be on your side all the time
and I don't know if he's ever gonna Peak
like the way DeSantis is peaking today
right because you Peak when there's
crisis and he's peaking yep so it's not
four years from now irrelevant that's
the story that's the challenge he runs
against Trump it's a tough one it's a
tough one because Trump's going to play
dirty and you have to go dirty as well
yourself and that's just going to happen
so it's not going to be a trump the
Santa's ticket you see a lot of guys
here putting Trump to Santa's ticket I I
think that is as unlikely as a Kobe and
Jordan being on the same team it just
doesn't make any team it's like putting
two big personalities on the same team
try to run together it's going to be
tough you need somebody to be Pippin you
need somebody to be the second you know
person neither one of them are guys like
that so if it's against Biden
if it's Biden being on the ticket
because right now what the left is
struggling with is who they gonna
replace Biden with what's their story
going to be how they're going to present
it to the audience the only way you can
do it the right way is you have to come
up with a health story in the next 12
months is probably what's going to
happen the next 12 months that Biden's
going to come out and going to say I
went and had a test with the doctor and
the doctor's telling me I have a cyst or
I have something and unfortunately we're
trying to do our best and if you hear
stories like that that is the narrative
which is kind of like The Narrative of
soft landing and saying oh my gosh you
know you know he was President while he
was dealing with cancer what a honorable
man so then we're the uh America is
going to get emotionally sentimental
look he was doing his best while he was
dealing with cancer some story like that
maybe it's cancer replace cancer or
whatever else you want to replace it
with but they have to find a candidate
it ain't Kamala nobody likes not the
left not the right not the middle nobody
likes Kamal and then let me just say
this too before I want to hear you face
this because I was saying that a lot of
people on the left don't come into
contact with objective reality it's the
same thing with the right there are a
lot of people on the right now who like
you know who don't the people that are
making decisions tend to be they're
looked at by Americans as being very
wealthy and out of touch as well right
so but but keep going I want to hear
yeah so who do you have so think about
what's left after that so then you got
to go to people to church which is who
they want to Market okay peanut butter
it's going to be very tough because of
foreign policy oh you'd be amazed how
many people behind closed I don't think
America gets right behind him is ready
for a first husband I'm being serious
yeah I agree like it's it's a it's like
America's where we've come a long way
but let me tell you something Brian
Callan I think we are ready for a gay
president yeah I just don't think we're
ready to see him kissing his husband on
TV yeah again gay president I'm okay
with that yeah walking down the the
Russians are going to be like that's
interesting oh this is your guess it's
really interesting and then Pat going up
well some say we've already
the rumors People Like Us that are like
listen Trump with the policy wise you
can't deny it okay and what pissing me
off again will my Democratic cousins
that are you know pretty liberal pretty
kind of leaning left this two years you
guys have had a chance to show us you
know what the hell with Trump you know
policies aside whatever look how good
we're doing look at what's happened in
these two years now because of your guys
besides policies you're giving him the
easiest way right back in so I don't
want to hear this [ __ ] talking when he
does win but I'm not I don't worry about
Democrats and I don't worry about
Republicans traditionally Democrats and
Republicans are no problem you got both
sides of the aisle that that's it makes
government move slowly that's that's how
the country was founded I got no problem
some people tend to lean more Democrat
more Republicans maybe it's a
personality type do you see what he just
put up I put a smile on my face go back
to the picture while he's talking you
put a picture like then you expect me to
keep a straight face that's so funny
look what he does how am I supposed to
keep it straight no way that is
hilarious is that a real picture no I
think that's corrupt that it's not a
real picture but it's funny is it a real
picture no it's not I was going to say
that's okay it's not it's not that he's
gay it's that he takes three months off
from attorney but certainly and he's
done and we had a supply chain crisis by
the way Matt Zeller believes it needs to
be two years no way
whom we'd love to have you back home
that the lead needs to be two years but
who's gonna pay for it exactly you're
going to pay for it so go back to the
you don't have problem with the Democrat
you don't have problems
my issue is this far left woke agenda
that has taken hold they are when you
start talking about when the New York
Times runs 81 articles I think on gender
neutral bathrooms
when the world's on fire and this was
back when I think it was a couple years
ago it's like you're so out of touch
with how Americans think you're so out
of touch when trans rights are trumping
everything else dude you're talking
about a very tiny tiny minority of
people that when when you want to take
children and put them on puberty
blockers because you're an expert in in
gender dysphoria I don't no you're not
no you're not and I don't agree let a
child's brain develop they go through
phases you know these are common sense
things and when the left hijacks when
they start doing that the far left
starts doing that and they drown out the
reasonable voices what happens is it it
creates a whole bunch of people on this
side who go you want to go to war dude
you want to go to war we can do this I
that's what I worry about I worry that I
really worry when I hear
people over there talking about tearing
down institutions
and
characterizing the United States as only
a patriarchy a tyranny a racist country
all those things okay we're a lot more
than that we are a lot more just like a
human being is Sinners Saints and
everything in between bipolar apes and
so is a country who are working progress
we're a work in progress this was called
the Grand experiment for a reason it's
still going on the Constitution is a
verb the United States is a verb it's an
idea that continues to evolve okay but I
think the founding fathers solve the
political problem okay a little a little
credit where it's due the words you use
like feminism individualism universalism
humanism all those words were invented
by the people you're criticizing and by
a system you're criticizing the First
Amendment which you enjoy very much and
saying what you want and screaming was
fought for it was fought for with blood
and it had to be fought for as an idea
and it had to be one as an idea all
those things that we benefit from every
day you may be a socialist I respect you
but you're also tweeting from your
iPhone so a little respect for the
marketplace as well if you could right
let's be let's be aware of where we came
from let's be aware of the kind of
foundation that was laid for us before
we got here that we benefit from every
single day because whether you know it
or not your anchor is in that bedrock
and thank God for it because the
Founding Fathers as far as I concerned
solve the political problem you know who
didn't the Greeks and everybody else so
there James Madison Alexander Hamilton
you're talking about John Jay you're
talking about genius The Federalist
Papers is one of the or the greatest
idea in philosophy I'm sorry it is and
why do I say that because we still live
in the greatest country in the world
because everybody has a chance we still
have potential I need music when I'm
talking away
you should have been standing up with
your hand on your heart when you run it
is
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]